my mom was followed by a murderer and
this is that story all right so this
story goes all the way back to the
mid-1970s so this is my mom's junior
year of high school well it was the end
of her junior year of high school I
guess I should say actually it was the
start of her summer vacation it was a
beautiful day so my mom her sister and
her friend decided to take a little day
trip so the three of them hop in the car
and they're off so it takes them about
two and a half hours to get there
they're listening to the radio talking
about things they want to do for the
summer and eventually they arrive at
their destination Oak Creek Canyon Park
so for context this trip and this entire
story is all taking place in northern
Arizona the park there at sits in the
middle of Coconino National Forest so
one of the main reasons they wanted to
go to this park is because it's
absolutely gorgeous over there there's
trees mountains one of the things they
notice when they get there is that it is
very open almost too open so they parked
the car in a small parking lot and they
start scoping out an area for them to
hang out they end up plopping down with
a small pond by the park with plans to
just hang out for a few hours they had
brought some food they were maybe gonna
do a picnic they didn't really know
other than the fact that they were just
enjoying that summer had just begun I
feel like it's important to mention that
my mom has been to this park before
she's been there a few times with some
friends and whatnot but it was very
empty that day which was strange for
such a nice day anyway so there they are
just hanging out when suddenly my mom
notices a man across the pond a couple
of minutes go by and my mom's sitting
there trying to stay engaged in the
conversation with her sister when she
stares back across the pond the man is
still standing there he's staring at
them rubbing his chin thoughtfully like
I see you obviously my mom's first
thought is what the hell is this guy
doing out here by himself and why is he
staring at us like that trying her best
not to stare back she does a few quick
glances at best and she notices his
clothes he's really well-dressed which
is just another weird detail that didn't
seem to add up to my mom we should just
move to another area I'm getting really
creeped out she thought to herself after
deciding that this situation isn't
normal
she gets the attention of her sister and
her friend pointing out the man staring
at them across the pond they tell her
she's overthinking it and she's just
being crazy
he's probably they're just enjoying the
park like anyone else would
it is a public park after all and you
know they were probably right people
allowed to be outside people are allowed
to go to public parks whatever still
feeling uneasy my mom tries her best to
go back to just enjoying her day out of
the corner of her eye she notices a
slight movement instantly her eyes dart
back across the pond the man isn't there
anymore
suddenly she catches sight of the man
he's walking along the edge of the pond
headed there direction
the scariest part he was walking with
intention
he was walking toward them and to my mom
that was it so as to not escalate the
situation any further because my mom had
no idea what was gonna happen
my mom softly but sternly pointed out
the man walking across the pond finally
they all agree that something wasn't
right about this situation and that they
should move now as quickly and quietly
as they could they gathered their things
and headed back to the car all the while
my mom is sneaking glances at me he was
still there walking with an even quicker
pace than he was before closing in on
where they had just been seconds before
my mom will say to this day she had the
worst feeling in the pit of her stomach
she was practically hyperventilating out
of fear instinct caution whatever you
want to call it my mom picks up a rock
on the way to the car they reach the car
they throw their stuff in the trunk and
the Pilon my mom is hunched over in the
backseat clutching the rock for dear
life she peeks out the back window as
the car starts she doesn't see him
wherever he was they needed to get out
of there with the tires practically
squealing out of the parking lot they
raced down the same road they drove in
on at this point everyone's eyes are
glued to the rearview mirror so that was
weird
my mom thought to herself rocking hand
my mom was definitely shaken up my mom's
sister the one who was driving the car
quickly looks in the rearview mirror and
she says oh my God look the energy in
the air it felt cold
they just felt wrong slowly my mom peers
out the back window one more time to her
horror she sees a car emerging from the
same parking lot following them she'll
never forget the feeling of watching a
yellowish cream-colored Volkswagen
Beetle it's slowly gaining ground on
them now everyone was truly terrified
what did this person want why was he
following them all my mom knew was this
person is evil she could feel it
her sister floors the gas pedal and
luckily they're able to maintain a
distance between themselves and this man
eventually they get to a gas station and
they pull over to what they hope is
safety to their surprise and ultimately
their relief the man drives right by
them my mom
my mom's sister and her friend they were
all really unsettled by the whole thing
now you're probably wondering why I just
told you that story please don't go
anywhere I'm about to explain the
craziest part so about 15 years go by my
mom's just at home minding her own
business watching the news when she sees
that convicted serial killer Ted Bundy
was about to be sentenced to death she's
watching the news learning more about
this man and she learns that he was well
dressed he drove a yellow cream-colored
Volkswagen Beetle and he committed
several murders in Colorado which is
right above Arizona and as she's
watching the news the phone rings my
mom's sister my aunt who was with her
when this happened all those years ago
is watching the same broadcast when she
calls my mom and without even saying
hello
the very first thing my aunt says is do
you think it was him and without missing
a beat my mom slowly says I know it was
him
[Music]